j'ai aucun intérêt pour les sélections
j'ai la politique pourraient bien voter
mais je leur dirai que n'y aura pas
réellement de différence
70% des autochtones de 18 à 34 ans
disent avoir voté aux dernières
élections fédérales soit le même
pourcentage que l'ensemble des jeunes
électeurs canadiens et toujours selon
élections canada 34 % des jeunes
autochtones se disait très intéressé par
la politique canadienne en 2015
contrairement à 28 % des jeunes
canadiens
quatre ans plus tard on est allé
rencontrer des jeunes électeurs
autochtones pour voir comment se portent
leur intérêt pour la campagne fédérale
alors on a fait des faux bulletins de
vote
voilà la première question c'est
irez-vous voter le 21
[Musique]
j'ai répondu oui
et parce que sur mon va suivre nos mères
puis on va aller voter avec elle je
condamne et là des mensonges plus des
paroles en l'air
j'y allais quand j'ai eu 18 ans
m'intéresse plus ben oui parce que je
pense que c'est le devant de toute
l'histoire et d'aller voter pour
[Musique]
je me sens pas inclus là dedans et
beaucoup mieux je me sens pas représenté
j'aimerais ça avoir un intérêt pour
semer la politique c'est un peu
compliqué puis avec le secondaire on en
parle beaucoup étant une membre de
première nation c'est encore plus mon
devoir qu'un québécois d'aller voter
pour les parents jeu comme dans le cas
de mme thibout touquet ce qui est
touchant point cette très bonne chose
c'est quand même un gros enjeu parce que
les jeunes tout autant toute nation
devraient apprendre plus sur les
premières nations à genève
nous partageons un comme le même
territoire
mais nous nous sentons comme comme si on
était des marchés environnants c'est sûr
que c'est quelque chose qui était
important pour nous dire maintenant ça
va ensemble les premières nations pin
environnement
[Musique]
qu'il soit 5,16 soir ce que je vois
c'est que les politiciens ils racontent
beaucoup de choses disent beaucoup de
choses de ce qu'ils vont faire
graduellement meilleur de près le trois
quarts qui sont un peu plus mis de côté
je pense qu est ce qu il faudrait faire
c'est agir au lieu de parler avait plus
de candidats autochtones
je suis me sentir plus concernés
[Musique]